victor davis hanson
is a senior fellow at the hoover
institution we're always happy to have
him join us professor thanks so much for
coming on this is an about face what do
you make of it
well it's not because tucker they found
a new agenda this new socialist agenda
that was so popular i think what
happened is the first thing they be the
democratic party became wealthy that by
coastal elite right through
globalization got these global markets
and you have a whole professional class
that's not subject to any ramifications
of these utopian ideas whether it's
climate change or defund the police and
never boomerangs back on them and then
they they said well we don't have the
people but we have the institutions
corporate boardrooms wall street silicon
valley k-12 academia so we can influence
opinion without having a majority of
opinion
and then of course they changed the
demography we've had about 40 million
people come in the last 40 years and
right now we have 50 million american
residents that were not born the united
states
and they feel that the majority of them
will be loyal to the democratic party
that invited them in and still it's not
enough still that they're looking at a
disaster
uh in november so now they're saying
well you know what in good jacobin or
bolshevik fashion we've got to
re-educate young people get them why
they're young indoctrinate them
or they're
and and so that they're trying to do
that and they want to change the system
they're saying well if we can't
indoctrinate them maybe we can get rid
of the filibuster or get rid of the
electoral college or pack the court or
have a national voting law but all of
this has a common denominator and that
is they are the party of the elite now
they're the party of the wealthy the
party that despises the middle class and
they seek power for an agenda that
nobody wants and they have to have these
crises to do it january 6
or the ukrainian war whatever the thing
is they use these levers of influence
and power and it's still i don't think
it's going to be enough i think they're
looking at a landslide
of rejection in november and i think
that
elon musk is a precursor so was the
c-span uh implosion so was the disney
implosion so it was a netflix implosion
so it was a virginia election implosion
a lot of indicators a lot of symptoms
that they have a reckoning that's
terrifying in them
well and just in three sentences
do you believe that the coming midterms
will discredit not just the players but
their ideas as well
yeah i think it is because you see it's
not just political people
as you say they're not really interested
just in the issues it's existential they
can't find food that they can afford
they can't fill up their car they don't
feel safe when they go into a big city
they don't feel their kids are being
educated or they're being propagandized
so it's a 360 24 7 phenomenon it's a
totalitarian effort and you can see the
pushback in social media you can see it
was grassroots school board it's not
just political they feel their very
lives are at stake it's not going to be
sustainable if these people are in
control any longer because they don't
care joe biden doesn't care about the
the price of gas elizabeth warren
doesn't care if people can't afford you
know plywood at the lumber store they
don't care yeah
they're revolutionaries or idologs again
they'd rather be wrong
and they'd rather lose and be right than
be wrong and win that's how ideological
they are i think you're right i think
that's a really insightful observation
victory was hansen thank you very much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight